I'm sitting here with Mike wails he's
one of our front-end developers how you
doing good so what are we talking about
we're talking about giving things with
no context whatsoever like his interview
does interview okay so have you ever
been in a situation where someone has
handed you a whole bunch of code written
in a framework you've never seen before
okay you've never seen this code itself
before mmm and you hardly know what it
does and they give you some task to do
oh yeah all the time all that really
it's pretty common tell me a little bit
about the feeling behind that like what
what does it feel like when someone
hands you this big yeah mess um it's a
daunting task at first because like you
said they've handed you a big mess and
you have no idea what's going on so you
just gotta kind of have to make a plan
of attack and and how are you going to
figure out what's going on and how are
you going to get the right amount of
context to accomplish the task that's
been handed to you yeah I mean one of
the things is it feels like a big mess
not because it necessarily is but
because you don't have that cuz just new
to you exactly yeah so how would you go
about getting that context the first
thing I would do is try and track down
what libraries or frameworks that
application might be using and hopefully
it's something popular or something well
documented and I would just dive into
the documentation of that library or
that framework now are you looking to
get a lot of specific information like
really become an expert in this
framework or are you looking for no big
picture yeah just a big picture just
kind of where is stuff at in this
framework what are the best practices
that this framework establishes just so
I can figure out because I mean I have
this task I need to accomplish I don't
have time to sit here and learn a whole
framework so just to kind of or where do
I need to look in the application code
to get this problem solved yeah and
pretty much all organizational libraries
and frameworks are the same I mean they
all have models they all have
collections I mean they all call them
different things right like for example
knock out calls them observable arrays
rather than collections or something
like that yeah Michael would just be to
find out what does this framework call
it and where is it at got it so that's
to enable you to figure out in your code
that you've been given where to look to
implement the feature that you want to
implement exactly otherwise I have to
sit there and read the
entire application code and who knows
how long that's going to be all right
that makes sense so what about if your
framework or library doesn't have
documentation or doesn't have good
documentation burn it all down and redo
it no no don't do that don't do that I'm
kidding um then you just have to you
have to spin the time to read through
the application code and and just
understand it and you should estimate
the time required for that task to now
be like five times as much as your
original estimate so legacy code can be
pretty absolutely if it's not documented
well yeah awesome well thanks for sit
with mimic